lots of people are picking up a new
hobby bird watching has surged in
popularity over the last year
from simple window feeders to outdoor
excursions the online database ebird
reports a 37 percent increase in users
documenting their sightings
and more than 2 million people used the
merlin bird id app
in 2020 bird watching is almost like a
meditation
and i think people need that especially
right now
well part of the appeal is being able to
bird watch anywhere and in all seasons
and to connect with others while staying
socially distant
social media has helped the hobby take
flight and attract
younger bird watchers and wouldn't you
know a little birdie told us it's
world wildlife day tomorrow and that
little birdie of course rocky diaz
she joins us from the henderson bird
viewing preserve with how we can take a
walk on the wild side here in vegas hey
rocky
hey kirsten yeah so i'm so glad you guys
told that story because lisa here was
just telling me about
ebird.com right yeah and you guys use
that here at the preserve we do you can
go on ebert and if you put in henderson
bird viewing preserve
you'll see that birders have put what
birds they've seen here today so you
know what to expect when you come out
wow okay so we'll get to the you know
how to properly bird here
at the henderson spot but first i want
to know about this land look at this
vast beautiful land where are we right
now and how did this come about
so the henderson bird viewing preserve
actually sits on the water reclamation
facilities property it's over 100 acres
and there's nine evaporation ponds
that the water reclamation facility uses
and uh it kind of started back in the
70s with the ponds here the birds
naturally came
as a place to live or rest on their
migratory travels
and where there's birds there's going to
be birders right
eventually the audubon society's
christmas bird count
added this spot to their annual uh bird
count
and in 1998 we opened up the henderson
bird viewing preserve to the public
that is amazing and you've told me
before too that nevada is among the most
diverse
birds in the world yeah so you can see
over 200
species of birds here at the bird
viewing preserve throughout the year and
nevada
in general sees even more than that
different varieties of birds
wow that's so cool and i mean honestly
i'm a rookie here
this is my first time bird viewing and
it's so much fun it's also a really
peaceful activity safe activity you can
do
during this time and i'm wondering you
know i've heard a lot of different
sounds
walking through here is there a certain
bird call that you would do to try to
attract them over
how does that work so instead of a bird
call you're probably going to need a lot
of patience to sit down and wait for the
birds to come to you but some
professional birders do use bird calls
to identify the birds instead of through
their physical features
interesting okay well i do i also want
to let you guys know obviously
like we mentioned earlier world wildlife
day is tomorrow
and in vegas you don't think you know
there's a lot of wildlife here but there
is it's the henderson bird viewing
preserve here and then we have the lions
habitat ranch
we have camel safari there's camels in
the valley did you know that i didn't
know that
see you got to celebrate tomorrow and
beyond so thank you guys i'm ready to go
you know see more about what you have to
offer here i feel like i'm missing
a few tools yeah so we're going to want
to remember to bring our binoculars wait
don't tell everybody yet we're going to
tell you what you need
to properly bird watch coming up later
in the show
i'll send it back to you all right rocky